hop
ça commence
[Musique]
e
draka
[Musique]
c'est là
on est dans les temps l'art est mort
dans l'âme
le décor
et alors me dis donc c'est ma corde
[Musique]
regarde on peut réaliser les ne l'est
plus rapide du monde simplement en
pliant la corde et ap
hong hanh
il est vrai
mais maintenant sans lâcher les
extrémités de la corde
un simple mouvement
et hop le effet
évidemment rate un truc tu penses que
c'est un peu normal mais il est toujours
magique un regard une pichenette et il
s'en va compenser ce que tu fais avec ça
mais c'est un homme âgé de quatre
attaques ni tables bravo atatra mais ce
n'est pas fini car je vais maintenant de
montrer le nuit diot celui qui se fait
tout seul les doigts ne bouge pas les
mains se rapproche et le ne se forme
mais bien entendu c'est toujours un
noeud réel il revient et maintenant un
équilibre
on lance l'accord et on rattrape
[Musique]
tout se mélange mais si l'on fait très
attention
on arrive à faire se croiser
[Musique]
attention
on lance la corde
et maintenant hop on obtient 1 et
waratahs tricot ou n'est pas sérieux du
tout j'ai maintenant te montrer comment
faire un noeud en faisant une boucle
avec la main droite et en lançant
l'extrémité gauche dans cette boucle
mais si l'on fait une boucle avec la
main gauche une petite boucle
on peut la faire rentrer dans la boucle
de la main droite regarde bien hâte un
truc on synchronise les deux mouvements
et voilà mais c'est encore un est
magique car sur le place dans le dos le
disparu
il n'est pas tout à fait disparu
regardera truc il est là et oui regarde
les a dit
[Musique]
à
oh
m
[Musique]
ah bon
à
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
m
on
oh
tous
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
et bien maintenant on va parler du truc
j'aimerais y a un truc mais oui c'est
vrai j'ai un très très très facile je
devrai garder un petit cube est
maintenant une des 100 et s'arrête quand
on veut rien c'est alors et c'est
alberto tu lui dis stop quand tu veux
d'accord je t'aime tu vois la crise
quand tu veux stop
or il va jusqu'en bas et bien pour
réaliser ce petit tour il nous faut
seulement des cartes à jouer
voilà pour faire un cube quatre cartes
rouges par exemple les deux bleus
défient 6 szavay 6 semaines sans colle
grâce à une technique secrète qu'on va
expliquer ton temps portillo pour couper
une corde
la voilà vous avez oublié fils à
remercie mes dix doigts agiles et oui un
truc elle a un fils mais il n'est secret
faut pas le dire à vos amis un parce que
vous allez voir comment on fait
alors on commence à prendre car tel est
plié de la façon suivante on prend une
carte une autre en travers et amplis
com/sipa pris le bord voilà ainsi si on
fait la même chose de l'autre côté vous
avez ensuite des cartes publiées tout de
la même façon permettent de réaliser ce
petit montage place des cas comme ceux
là qui est
voilà encore un cas à part dessus vous
tenez tout ça bien précautionneusement
donc on obtient j'en ai un qui tous
prévenus on obtient cette forme là il ne
faut pas coller il faut que ça tienne
nous dire in what we et dessus la même
chose mais on a fait des trous avec vos
ciseaux avait simplement fait des tours
on va pouvoir coincé hop comme ceci
pourrait vous amuserez à faire ce petit
jeu de construction de l'autre côté
ainsi se tient si formule 1 alors voilà
de l'autre côté et tout le secret c'est
de passer la corde à l'intérieur mais on
ne dit jamais qu'à l'extérieur passe un
fil
le truc est oui alors ce fils il faut la
tâche est en haut de la corde comme cela
mais je crois qu'il est on a pris un
gros fil blanc mais en vérité je vous
conseille de prendre un petit film cry
voilà ce sera plus évident avec le fil
blanc si rien de fini
à donc si vous avez le fils qui est à
l'extérieur en le serrant contre le cab
s'accroissent voilà ça coince guigou le
tournoi mais si vous lâchez un peu une
dé 100 anciens brise tu y arrives se
voir voilà son break
alors évidemment les amis il faut se
mettre dans l'angle où on ne voit pas le
film il la fin 1 elle le fait très bien
or si l'info hostens jure il y avait un
truc
où
[Musique]
là
ans
ma
oh
[Musique]
hé hé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon succès à l'arraché 3
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouais